so the U.S women's soccer team uh they
lost and everybody's making fun of Megan
Rapinoe for missing what is considered
to be a very easy penalty kick costing
the U.S the match they have been
eliminated and you know I feel like for
most people most people who are who are
into politics and culture if this
individual was if Megan rapping knows
like a nice humble person we have
someone's audience blasting
okay if Megan weapon was a good person
that people really liked we'd all be
like nah it's cool you missed this shot
but we got your back thank you for
everything you do but but she's
insufferable she's got this viral video
where she screams I deserve this over
and over again she's got this video
people are dragging her where someone
this little this little kid wants a
signature on a soccer ball and she just
like Signs it and doesn't even look at
him just passes it off like he's not
even there and so she's a nasty person
Trump roaster saying nice shot Megan
blaming Joe Biden and wokeness for the
loss and this is the U.S losing on the
international stage not the biggest
story in the world but culturally
relevant because it's a component of get
well go broke no one's got your back
when you hate this country no one's got
your back when you're supposed to be
representing the us and then you refuse
to sing the national anthem so we'll
talk about that one we got uh actual
news I mean we could leave with this but
uh the US is dispatching warships
because there is this uh big China and
Russia we're seeing off the coast of
Alaska and said he was a little worried
about it but you know these things
happen you know it's it's not the
biggest deal in the world and uh another
really big story I owe a sincere apology
to Neo and I really do mean it because I
made it I made it pretty I was I was
pissed off uh Neo the Entertainer came
out did an interview where he was like
how are parents gonna let their kids do
these things decide these things for
their lives are five six seven years old
12 years old making permanent
alterations to their body he was very
critical of what what the left calls
gender affirming care and things like
that and uh we were all pretty happy
that he was speaking up and giving his
opinion and then
he tweeted an apology
and so I roasted him pretty heavily for
this saying this guy claims to be a
father and it's all that matters but
he's selling out his children's future
for Fame and Fortune with this apology
well I I apologize Neo uh because
apparently that was your publicist he
came out and said I don't care what the
publicist said I stand by what I said
and he doubled down and defended his
position saying kids shouldn't be doing
this and so uh yeah I apologize I uh you
know to be fair I had no idea that was
coming from a publicist and he he
apparently was not okay with it but uh
all that matters is he came out he he
said something very very legit defended
his stance said you know F the publicist
and for that I apologize we're going to
talk about all of that and more before
we get started my friends head over to
castbrew.com if you want to support the
show this is our coffee company buy our
coffee it's the best company
it's a great company but it's the best
coffee you'll ever have we've got the
cast Brew Coffee Club ground and whole
bean you get three bags of coffee every
month or you can just buy them uh each
bag straight up whole bean or ground we
got light we got medium we got dark
roast we got Mr bocus pumpkin spice
experience we got sleepy Joe decaf and
get the get this the current cups are
almost ready to launch you can see here
they're they're on the website but
they're still in the sold out position
because we're about to stock them but
the website is ready and uh we will have
these K-Cups very very very soon so
again go to castbrew.com buy our coffee
to support the show head over to
timcast.com click join us become a
member because one of the members only
uncensored show coming up for you at 10
p.m tonight where you as members can
submit questions and be selected to call
into the show talk to us and our guests
so smash that like button subscribe to
this channel share this show with your
friends if you really do like it copy
that URL paste it everywhere share it on
Twitter whatever you I'm I'm sorry on x
joining us tonight to talk about this
and so much more is Clint Russell
I am the number one uh fan club curator
for Neo uh you guys may have heard of me
no I'm uh
Clinton Russell host of liberty lockdown
as well as Tower gang I am a mises
caucus member LP National member Dave
Smith surrogate you know the thing thank
you guys for checking us out right on
how you doing I am Phil Labonte lead
singer of All That Remains uh
anti-communist and counter revolutionary
Claire brimlow I'm a writer for Tim cast
because I think it is the best company
or at least my favorite part of this
company yeah it was Tim was in Tim was
not out of line just to plug his own
company yeah I think you can call your
own company
as long as you know what the Donald
Trump hands then I'm fine uh but yeah
we all do agree everyone agree uh but
yeah anyways uh at least that's what I
want to be here and serge is here yes I
am indeed here that's gonna be a fun one
good to have you back Clint as always
thank you brother cheers all right let's
get started Tim ladies and gentlemen the
US has been eliminated from the uh the
World Cup U.S women's national team
historic early World Cup elimination
Trump mocks Megan Rapinoe he blames Joe
Biden Nice Shot Megan the USA is going
to hell Donald Trump reignited his Feud
with Megan Rapinoe as the former
president and other right-wing
commentators delighted in the national
team's historic early elimination from
the World Cup quote the shocking and
totally unexpected loss by the U.S
women's soccer team to Sweden is fully
emblematic of what is happening to our
once great nation under crooked Joe
Biden Trump wrote on his media platform
truth that means he truth did many of
our players were openly hostile to
America no other country behaved in such
a manner or even close woke equals
failure if Trump could just say get well
go bro Nice Shot Megan the USA is going
to hell you know why I'm not a fan of
these these statements I'm not a fan of
people being like Oh look you know them
losing his proof and all this stuff
because they were winning before they
had won twice they had done a really
good job she was still Megan rap and I
was still is still a really awful person
that nobody likes uh well actually a lot
of people do like her come on I'm being
hyperbolic but she's divisive you know a
lot of people in this country don't like
her a lot of people seem to like her and
so she is supposed to represent the USA
But actively despises it and speaks out
against its history she encourages
people not to stand for the for the
national anthem or or sing the
Star-Spangled Banner and things like
that
if you're going overseas to represent
the USA you should be proudly
representing the USA if you don't like
this country you should not be in this
position and so it's I'm not going to
sit here and rag on her and be like haha
what an awful player she screwed up this
one time she missed a penalty kick it is
kind of embarrassing she loses she
laughed about it when it happened she
started crying later but the funny thing
is when she's crying it also looks like
she's laughing too she starts like
acting like she's crying and then she
looks up and she's smiling and laughing
here's my conspiracy theory
she missed it on purpose
because she wanted to she's retiring her
and a couple other players apparently
are retiring they're done they're like
let's take our early exit take our cash
do our endorsement deals we out
conspiracy theory that's an interesting
one I I don't know how that would help
with endorsements to not three-peat
because she's a grifting leftist
activist she gets endorsements not based
on the fact that she's winning games
she's coming out and saying whatever the
left wants to hear that's I mean it's
not impossible but she's already rich
too yes she I mean she's working with
Victoria's Secret she's part of their
like more inclusive lady campaign I'm
not really sure what it's about yeah
people were really mad when they picked
her in particular Victoria's Secret
bring back hot models right I mean maybe
she wants to have in her legs from
soccer so she can get in on the final
year of the Biden Administration she's
been there talking about inequalities in
women's sports pay because obviously uh
women's soccer makes so much money uh
that we can justify these kinds of
complaints
herself is the face of Oppression Henry
has economics in one lesson would fix
that would fix this problem no but the
thing is she's the kind of person from
the quotes that I've heard of her
talking about how you can't escape
inequality who would say like no I don't
believe you the things that I feel are
more important than any kind of logic
frustrating we have we have two
potentialities here Megan Rapinoe is uh
bad you know she has one in the past but
how do you screw up what is what is uh
all these articles are talking about how
it's a penalty kick it's an easy shot
and she went over the net and lost
so is she just not the person for this
game is she is she not the people the
person that people should be cheering
for is not that good
did you make a simple mistake or did she
Spike the game because she wants to
leave early and not have to spend how
much more time overseas flying around
playing these games I think it would
have only been a couple more weeks so I
I doubt I doubt she she blew it
intentionally I think she's over the
hill and her her focus is on activism as
opposed to the sport and I think it's as
simple as that is that like then she
gets there on the big stage she hasn't
been committed to the sport like she had
her entire career and she chokes when it
matters most yeah I mean she didn't she
didn't I wasn't like the everyone's
saying that the goalie played a great
game which she did but she also
completely went over the net it was like
not even close to like on target so yeah
but there was other players that did the
same thing right that's true one of the
youngest players did the exact same is
always successful yeah
um but look can we just get back to a
period in American history where like
the the idea of whether or not the US is
either in heaven or hell is not dictated
based off of women's soccer I think
that's so strange to me no Clint we
actually can't we're going shut up hell
why what is Trump talking about well
there's there's another story that was
going on a couple days Joe Rogan
drinking Bud Light and and numerous
times on his show saying that's like
silly and who cares and stuff like that
but uh I I think it matters I think when
you see
Megan Rapinoe trying to represent a sect
of American politics instead of the
United States that's the corruption that
that we have to say no to oh yeah and
reject the person who goes and
represents the United States states
should say something like
I am deeply critical of this country's
history but I am here to represent those
who both love and are critical and for
all of my you know all of the people in
the United States who may disagree with
me just know that I'm going to win this
for you too and that's what's supposed
to be representing everybody she doesn't
she hates us her criticism she has ample
opportunity to let people know that
she's critical without doing it when
she's representing the United States
when she's overseas you can have
whatever opinion you want but when
you're out actually being a
representative of the United States you
should not trash the United States and
to be honest with you this is a real
real real low bar to pass this is a very
easy ask
um you know saying don't trash America
when you're out there getting paid
significant money and and being in a
position to get all sorts of sponsorship
deals and all kinds of stuff like that
don't trash America when you're out
there being a representative low bar to
pass and if you can't I don't see why
people should support you I got a
devil's advocate this because I love
Megan Rapinoe into the blue hair yes she
is yes she's my spirit what do you got
Clint uh no I think that there's there's
a a reasonable argue to be made that
like for instance
if there was if Megan Rapinoe was out
there and she was saying we need to
avoid World War III with Russia and she
was critical of our our military in this
moment or critical of our state
department I would have been like
awesome yeah
going into Forbes Megan Rapido made
seven million dollars in the past year
oh God she's worse
for you you guys you guys ready for this
one here you go here you go you guys
ready
you deserve all of it everything you
deserve this
she belongs
that's the cringiest thing what a girl
boss wow what do you have to say
she lost I'm so happy she's the one who
spiked it bro you give me anyone any
athlete and if they if if they keep
their mouth shut and say literally
nothing and then there it's a it's a
penalty kick or it's a free throw and
they miss and they come back and they
say I'm sorry everybody I'm sorry I let
you down I tried my best just now I'm
gonna train we're gonna bet we got your
back dude we know you you did you you
played the game you gave it you gave it
your all we respect you this video right
here what whatever it is no one's
calling it a joke
no one on the left is being like ah she
was kidding they're not even saying that
no what is what do they say
they say they say that's a mood post
said uh here you go Megan Rapinoe
holding World Cup trophy and screaming I
deserve this is a mood
yeah okay this is from four years ago no
this is an insufferable arrogant
entitled person who absolutely
represents the worst scum of the United
States the entitled Millennial who
screams I deserve this well just just
you would never hear Tom Brady do that
well just contrast it with the greatest
athlete of all time Tom Brady well don't
don't do this to me Phil Michael Jordan
uh but he would he would hug the trophy
and he would kiss it and he was known
for being quite the but he was
just like in that moment he's he's
tearful he's he's appreciative he's
hugging his teammates he's hugging the
truth he's crying thank you very much
thank you all for the support I want to
thank God I want to thank my family for
being there we all worked really hard my
teammates they all helped him go I
deserve this could you imagine
it's just great no she could have been
holding trophy being like my teammates
helped me get here and I'm eternally
grateful no I deserve this it's her in
particular she is particularly sort of
self-absorbed I think that was that's
what makes her unpleasant like you're
saying a different person made a
terrible kick during this game we're not
talking about her we're only talking
about making rap no because she has made
especially women soccer but women's
sports generally this very divisive
issue both from the pay stuff from the
transgender stuff she uh love the
celebrity she got from some of their
wins and used it to be the one to kneel
on the field to be the one and women's
sport needs every single eyeball it can
get but instead she's like I am going to
make the most toxic and just just
objectionable
uncharismatic people that are just out
there so full of themselves they don't
sound like team players and it's just so
bad for women's sports and people are
just like all right I think I'm gonna go
I'm glad that like you know the NFL's
start got started preseason started last
week Real Sports God it's so bad
it is it feels so good knowing that she
missed an easy kick and spiked the game
for the United States and it's on her
and then she laughs about it I don't
even think she cares she's laughed no I
don't think she does care it bro there I
I remember when I was working this is
like 10 years ago I was advising we are
watching the World Cup and Brazil do you
remember that game in like 2013 I think
it was 2013 where Brazil lost like eight
zero it was just like the most brutal
defeat can we look that when was that
and people were crying
they were they were players crying there
were people crying as well it was what
it was to Sweden as well really yeah
they've been over like essentially our
Rivals US Women's National team was it
the 2014 World Cup what's it 2014. it
might have been 24. I'm asking does
anybody understand the argument that
they should have equal pay given that
they don't have as much in terms of
Revenue because I don't understand what
the argument is does anybody understand
it communism oh communism okay cool that
makes sense that's what I was assuming
it just makes them feel better that way
yeah I mean it doesn't make any sense
it's it's not a successful business
venture it's not generating it doesn't
make any sense it is about equal like
Equity it's about well we go out there
and we put in the same effort which
there's no way to measure the amount of
effort that they put in versus even if
they do who cares
we are more successful
make how much money
guys you guys you gotta understand okay
there's no women's sports anymore
because the reason why we need equals
this is heaven the reason why we need
equal pay is because we have the
sometimes people wear dresses Division
and the sometimes people wear pants
division
that's it
that's that's what they're breaking it
down by fair enough when the left says
women's sports they don't mean yeah they
don't need biological female they mean
people who sometimes wear dresses that's
it but but for real that's what that's
what it is and so I'm gonna get in the
Hall of Fame is it sometimes if Michael
Jordan put on a dress we're gonna pay
him less money no no Michael Jordan gets
paid the same even as wearing a dress or
he's wearing pants that's that's why we
need equal pay oh God it's Grace it's
true I just don't understand I just
don't understand the the argument it's
like it is honestly it is communist it's
bizarre to me that they just make it so
overtly and all right look I saw many
Hassan who's going ballistic about this
and he's like I'm so accustomed to
seeing all the conservatives the true
blue the hug the flag the shoot your
guns a two-way the Bible thumb and then
he goes he goes they always root for the
for the USA But now all of a sudden they
don't it's like yeah
they don't they don't root for us it's
provocation he does not actually care it
doesn't bother him no so the point that
he's making is trying to get people to
engage with him so that way he can be
dishonest it's not about whether or not
it's not about whether or not people are
patriotic he is trying to hold people to
a standard that is imaginary because he
does not hold those those positions at
all so it's just a communist provocation
flip him off
no
it makes me sad for all of the other
female players who are now come like
maybe it's a good thing that Megan Apple
was retiring and so there was a chance
for the women on this team to
potentially say like hey we don't agree
with her we don't want to be a part of
this political activism she has been our
team captain and dominated our culture
and made it so we are forced to behave
this way which of course they have their
choices they're allowed to do whatever
they want right but that's really the
only way to drive people back to women's
soccer they have to start winning again
which obviously I I don't play fresh
swords I don't know what kind of
challenge that is and they have to not
be the political epicenter of liberalism
right now yes well there will be uh a
huge sigh of relief by many of the
players on that team I would imagine
with her gone because she just sucked
the air out of every room well because
she deserves this because she deserves
this nobody else obviously no I mean she
deserves all of this right now yes she
does unreal yeah yeah this is this is it
man we you love to see Karma because you
want people to be respectful grateful
not nice to each other humble and she's
the epitome of arrogant leftism now to
have her losing this way yeah I'm
gloating I will glow it all the way same
yeah well and it reminds with Huffington
Post article came out first you got you
know women's Sports women's soccer was
performing well they were winning and
there were so many people who are saying
you know they we need to talk about them
more girls need these these uh folk
heroes in sports so they know they can
achieve all the stuff like they never
tell you why girls need that also no one
should look at Megan rapino and say I
would like to live life the way you do
because you treat people poorly you're
not a good you don't have good character
I think regardless of whether she's a
good athlete or not she is not the model
of behavior you'd want anyone to be like
look younger young child do that there's
another angle of of uh Ridiculousness to
this is that women's soccer really got a
head start on the rest of the World by
like 20 or 30 years so they have this
way overly inflated ego about their
position in the sport because they're
like look we're better than the men's
team compared to the rest of the world
it's like no no you got a head start on
the rest of the world because women
weren't really playing soccer or
football in the rest of the world so now
though now the rest of the world's
catching up and you're gonna have to get
real that uh we're probably gonna get
surpassed
yep well she deserves this she does I
mean I just yeah I'm not gonna shut it
to you we're gonna jump to this next
story I have to do this one right away
because I owe Neo an apology Neo defends
his opinion clarifies apology after
declaring opposition to Children
undergoing medical gender transition I
need you all to hear this from the
horse's mouth on the publicist computer
so let's break the story down we got
this from Rolling Stone Neo apologizes
for criticizing parents who support
children deciding their gender identity
saying gender identity is nuanced and I
can honestly admit that I plan to better
educate myself on the topic so I can
approach future conversations with more
empathy basically he goes on this
podcast and he's like kids can't decide
this stuff I feel like parents don't
know what it means to be parents anymore
if a kid comes and says he wants to eat
candy all day and you let him he'll do
it he says if your five-year-old son
comes because I feel like a girl you're
gonna rock with that he's like these
kids can't make these prominent life
decisions what ends up happening is he
puts out this post on Twitter saying I'd
like to express my deepest apologies
after much reflection I'd like to
express my deepest apologies to anyone
that it may have hurt with my comments
on parenting and gender identity they've
always been an advocate in love I
understand my comments could have been
interpreted gender identity is new ones
and I can honestly admit that I plan to
better educate myself on the top of
second approach blah blah blah I lead
with love and support well
about a video I'm gonna play this video
for you you can hear it straight from
him you guys ready yep what's going on
loved ones this is Neo all right listen
I normally don't give too much of a damn
about what y'all think about what I do
what y'all have to say about what I say
whatever I normally don't care because
like I said opinions ain't special
everybody got one however this is
something I feel very strongly on and I
need y'all to hear this from the horse's
mouth not the Public's computer so check
this out first and foremost I do not
apologize for having an opinion on this
matter I am a 43 year old heterosexual
man raising five boys and two girls okay
that's my reality now if my opinion
offended somebody yeah sure I apologize
for you being offended because that
wasn't my intention my intention is
never to offend anybody however I'm
entitled to feel how I feel I'm
absolutely entitled to feel how I feel
the same way you are entitled to feel
how you feel I ain't asked nobody to
follow me I ain't ask nobody to agree
with me I was asked the question and I
answered the damn question okay I have
no beef with the
lbgtqia plus Community whatsoever I
ain't got no beef with y'all do whatever
the hell it is you want to do do what
you want to do with your kids however
somebody asked my opinion on this matter
and this is how I feel I will never be
okay with allowing a child to make a
decision that detrimental to their life
I will never be okay with that I don't I
definitely plan to educate myself a
little bit more on this matter however I
doubt that there's any book
somebody's gonna tell me that's gonna
make me okay we're letting the child
make a decision like that that's just
period Point Blank and that's how I feel
if I get canceled for this then you know
what maybe this is a world where they
don't need a Neo no more wow and I got
no problem with that I'm a hustler I'll
figure it out I got kids to raise and
I'm gonna do that regardless so with
that being said
y'all have a good day I love everybody
live how you want to live love how you
want to love but your opinion is yours
speak your opinion as much as you damn
well feel like it because as I said
they're not important they're not
special everybody got one and you're
entitled to it I'm entitled to mine all
right y'all feel how y'all want to feel
have a great day it's Neo peace and love
so that that was not not only did he
come out and say no to that apology he
did it in a very very very strong way so
uh
I feel I look I I want to defend myself
a little bit like I had no idea who's
gonna do this of course most of these
celebrities come out and go oh I'm so
sorry oh wow I'm whiny baby this dude
just came out
manly 10 out of 10. like I was saying
you're not a man you're not a father no
no this dude is a real man is a real
father this is what father should be
doing that's what men should be doing he
did it right he was respectful he said
I'm not trying to offend you and I'm
like that's exactly right none of us are
trying to offend people we're trying to
express ourselves but I want to point
out you notice that I would never be
okay with a kid doing something that
detrimental to themselves yeah he's
outright saying it is harm it's not just
a how could you know like how could you
feel the way no he's not right saying
it's bad it's modern lobotomies yeah
literally well I think he's just telling
the truth but what's so what's so
remarkable about it is that in the music
industry in particular you just can't
get away with this like I I tweeted out
a couple hours ago like if you
appreciate this guy this honesty and if
you want to support this man and you
want to see more truth in the world it's
really important we really around this
dude because I think they're going to
come for him yeah I want to know what
happened with his publicist
he's like it's not
you're gonna hear from me and not the
public
computer which by the way we have to
note how many
Neo and this is my message by the way
it's me Neo like I signed off for his
name he's not afraid that this is his
opinion uh I I think it's interesting
that there was a statement released at
all and he's obviously not okay with it
I assume his bubbles is getting fired
probably rightly so but then what was
the conversation behind the scenes were
they like you have to put out a
statement he's like oh yeah let me think
about what I want to say and then I'll
comment on and they're like anyway so
we're posting this which didn't even
really it sounds like every gender
identity educated University bachelor's
degree person I've ever heard he's like
oh yes I will educate myself and this is
new and like it's generic this is
obviously much stronger and much fresher
I also think it's much more relatable to
parents who are like I'm not going to
change my I have a a million children to
raise and I'm not going to waver in this
did he say he's got seven kids yes five
kids five boys two girls I want to
clarify two because I don't know he said
but he's a singer but people have been
calling him a rapper no I just know he's
a singer yeah
yeah people people saying he deleted the
video I don't know oh no no where was it
posted I'm telling you his publicist has
access to his Twitter and that's the
problem was it posted to his Twitter I
don't know look it looks like an
Instagram thing to me but I'm not so up
on that let me let me just say wherever
this shakes out whatever post actually
ultimately ends up being the one of
record for Neo in this in this time
frame it is obvious this is who this guy
is hopefully it's the one where he's
beating up his level six like for
changing his stuff
change your password this is the moment
yeah dude like Break Free Break Free
it's it does seem crazy that they I mean
I don't know if that's actually deleted
so I don't want to like propagate false
information but uh I'm sure the internal
publicist who charges him thousands and
thousands of dollars to do their
services is now freaking out because
they're like no we already put out a
party line
the videos on his on his Instagram okay
I just checked all right great yeah
about what I say whatever yeah not only
that but like he's coming after the
media too because they got this one
story where it says Neo condemns parents
allowing children to transition and he's
he responded first and foremost I
condemn no one who might have condemned
anybody your life your kids your choice
I was asked a question I answered it my
opinion is mine I'm not asking anybody
to agree with me nor am I telling you
what you can and cannot do with your
children I said in my opinion on the
matter that's that why should i k why
should I care if my opinion upsets you
when you don't care if yours upsets
anyone opinions aren't special we all
have one people voice them regularly
whether they've asked or not dude that
was based why should I care if my
opinion upsets you when you don't care
if your opinion upsets anyone else yeah
that's exactly
good Lyricist over here that's been true
for you yeah so there you go I'm proud
of him I'll just say it I'm proud of him
yeah I want to buy some Neo Maro chapter
we got to get uh Neo Jersey or whatever
to hang on the wall like yeah yeah Luke
did with Kyrie Irving okay no but I
think there's something to be said about
that I mean why should he have to guard
his opinion based on what random people
on the internet think of him well what's
even listen to his music or you don't
like him don't freak out well what's
even crazier about it is like his
opinion is by all accounts unless you're
a lunatic reasonable he's saying that
children aren't prepared to make these
decisions that's it and then he's going
out of his way to say and I'm also not
condemning them let me take it another
step Neo I am condemning yeah if you're
a parent and you're actually allowing
your kid to make these decisions before
they're of age you're a bad parent
imagine absolutely being like my
five-year-old identifies as a cowboy so
I'm gonna buy him a gun
nah he could he could get hurt he thinks
he's a bird we're going skydiving this
is all
talking about to be fair with with a
proper instructor skydiving is nowhere
near as bad as like giving a child a gun
he's a race car driver so give him the
keys to the car right right go let him
do it there are tons of terrible
decisions parents could make I just
think this one is obviously one people
are questioning and especially since
this is not a minority opinion Neo is
actually among a lot of people who say
this is not something we should just
encourage they shouldn't be giving to
you they shouldn't be giving uh
teenagers plastic surgery of any kind no
yeah I mean yeah I was talking about
this the other day with some friends how
in uh I think in like Arizona it's
really big for teenage girls to get tons
of plastic surgery and I'm like that's
just it's not actually it's not as bad
it's not sterilizing them but it's still
really really bad and it's in a similar
category where we should not be telling
kids these kids are like my nose is bad
so I'm gonna get surgery no no no no no
no dude you you know what what's crazy
to me is that we live in this world
where people refuse to be themselves
just wait until you stop growing Bella
Hadid came out very famously and was
like I am I got a nose job when I was
like 14 15 something like that and I
regret it I my nose is part of my
ancestry I looked more like my relatives
and I am sad that I did that and you
know obviously she's a successful model
like things have been okay for her but
it is interesting that probably being
pushed into a modeling career they're
like you should change your nose and she
was like okay before she was old enough
to understand the consequences of the
decision so yeah you know it's funny you
know that song I think it's Christina
Aguilera I could be wrong you're
beautiful or whatever is it you're
beautiful and then it's like it shows a
whole bunch of goofy ass people in the
music video but it's like you're
beautiful or something like that yes yes
I thought it was funny that that was the
message a while ago where it's like no
matter who you are no matter what what
it is you know you you look like or
where you come from it was blunt
actually it was James Blunt yeah that's
that's tell me there I think uh there's
different there's differences I'm sure
there have been 100 music videos like
this I'm gonna love with you guys
James popular thought that's been shared
I mean it's the the marriage I think I'm
right
beautiful maybe James Blunt does have
one called your beauty I mean it is a
banger there are multiple songs you are
beautiful you are beautiful and ever
it's called Beautiful by Christina's
playlist immediately yo it's it's a
banger I'm sorry James Blunt is he
speaks it's called you are beautiful and
so we used to have this song
sorry we used to have the song where it
was like no matter what you looked like
you're good now it's like surgery awaits
if you're unhappy with your body yeah
okay yeah you're right that I mean
yeah we've uh we've gotten pretty far
away but it's it's it's the same with a
lot of things where it's just not really
accepting human nature or how we are
born or built it's it's dangerous the
trend line is not good I mean look I'm
I'm probably a little more Pro body
modification and stuff than anyone else
sitting at the table but if you're a kid
like this stuff is not for children
because your brain isn't developed like
you gotta you're not your brain isn't
fully developed until you're 25 or
something like that you want to you want
to get
surgeries that modify your body do it
when you're an adult you can live your
life as a as the opposite sex if you
want I'm not personally for that stuff
but at least those kind of things aren't
like they're not irreversible and
encouraging people to get
serious body modification before they're
even an adult is they're unconscionable
there's some that's that's like there's
a very degrees right a kid who wants to
get their ears pierced we don't really
care that much about right certain body
modifications like oh whatever like a
nose ring in the side or something yeah
they're like okay people want to kids
want to stretch their ears out and stuff
like that and it's like look I know tons
of people with plugs and stuff but it's
like and I used to have like gauged
earrings and stuff you probably
shouldn't be doing that until you're an
adult either because even those need
surgery to get me to repair if you get
them too stretched out I was gonna say
just the number of kids who turn 18 and
get tattoos tattoos are more and more
common in in this day and age which
doesn't have to be bad but I bet we can
all name someone whose parents said they
could get a tattoo at you know 17-16 and
they look at that tattoo and they're
like oh I regret this this was dumb of
course I mean then imagine it being your
genitalia I'm gonna write a song called
change your body because you're ugly and
you suck
and it's going to be a parody of these
your beautiful you are beautiful in
every single way and it's going to be
like no one likes you you don't fit in
you don't look like everyone else
therefore surgery awaits in Hollywood
and it goes on the Same album as insulin
resistance but but yes and but but think
about this this idea that the people who
claim and to believe in body positivity
are telling people to get surgeries to
look like other people like you don't
actually like their body you're Tom
you're telling them to go change
themselves instead of telling them that
they're fine the way they are
yeah well that used to be the message
it's completely inverted from what it
used to be it used to be like accept
yourself for who you are but this is the
same thing with like the you know the
colorblind movement it was like all
right that was basically the Civil
Rights idea was that we were going to
try and get past our immutable
characteristics and accept each other
for who we are as individuals blah blah
now you're aggressive and a racist if
you feel that way and it's the same
thing with body acceptance It's like
well we used to try and Advocate that
you just accept yourself for who you are
how you were born and now it's okay if
you want to completely change everything
from your DNA on it and it makes sense
why anxiety
yeah it's a crispr is coming yeah no it
is if it's not already here no I mean
people are already doing genetic
modification on themselves it seems
totally crazy I mean this makes sense
why people are so anxious and so in
search of identity because if you're
willing to modify your body to that
degree there's no there's no ceiling on
this you'll be always searching for the
next thrill more acceptance I don't feel
good yet I have to do the next thing I
have to do the next thing after the next
thing it's yes and that's ultimately one
of the things that wears in my Society
like to mentioned before with Megan
Rapinoe you know we don't feel like we
can root for her because she wouldn't
root for us she wouldn't root for the
country I mean if she would actively
root against us right if you don't root
for yourself as you are if you're
constantly seeking validation and things
around you and in physical modification
then how are you ever to be truly happy
I think that there's a lot of I think
there's multiple uh different reasons
people might want to modify their bodies
um and I don't think that it's just
people that are mentally ill or well I
don't think getting gauges in your ears
are the same thing as being like I would
like Top surgery please like very
different yeah but I mean there's
there's also in the future either like
the modifications that are the options
that people have for modifications
they're going to be
significantly more broad very very soon
and people that are going to decide I
want to have you know stronger arms
that's going to be an option people now
they can they can decide they want to
extend their legs nowadays there are
guys that will spend six months laid up
so they can get an extra two or three
inches of height and you know the things
that people will go to or the lengths
that people will go to to change their
bodies
if if people will do that for just a
couple inches of height imagine what
they would do for the ability to see you
know not just see better but have
superhuman vision and these things are
very close they're not that far away
what's actually you're talking 10 20
years ago they do this the hackers have
been doing this thing where you sew
magnets into your fingertips and that
gives you Electro I think it's called
Electro sense you put a neodymium magnet
under your skin and sew it up and then
what happens is the slight vibrations
from the electron electromagnetic
frequencies coming from electrical
appliances and cables cause a vibration
in the magnet pressing against the
nerves in your hand you can feel where
electricity comes from so you could
literally run your hand on the wall and
then feel where the the power lines are
running see and so like a MAG like a
neodymium magnet is extremely uh
non-invasive right it's not like putting
a machine in your hand but it still
doesn't work it doesn't work what do you
mean it eventually gets rejected oh yeah
it will shatter and break out of your
skin yeah so it doesn't stay but even
still like that's just obvi like you
said that was years and years and years
ago that people started doing doing that
and that's you know one guy even so home
biohacking one guy even put a full
computer in his arm under his skin like
crazy stuff I I think that the the
unintended consequence of all this body
modification and these like I don't know
hybrid human cyborg type things is that
ultimately I I can only speak for men in
this regard but when we had a shortfall
biologically you know whether it be our
height or whatever attractiveness we
would either become funny or become
musicians
you know like we would there there would
be something
just like go to a doctor and pay and
then be this specimen it kind of
detracts from that that other Avenue of
becoming a more impressive human being I
don't know let's remember Elon Musk uh
made a lot of money and then his
hairline came back that's true you know
I I think that there is a relationship
between like being self-aware enough to
say like look this may be and I don't
even think like some of the things we're
naming are not just like actually that
big of a deal like if you're not that
tall there are very short women in the
world you're fine uh the thing is like
there are lots of films
look I'll tell you I tell you what my
life would be extremely different if it
wasn't for the fact that I am a rock
star okay so being a rock star makes up
for at least three or four years
for sure dude so if he was 6'4 he would
have never even picked up the guitar
If I Was if I was six four I'd probably
rule the country see told you it's
actually a really good chance he played
basketball maybe yeah real though yeah
like the the taller you get the
percentage chance that you played
basketball gets higher and higher and
higher and there's something like if
you're if you're taller than six six
it's like a 17 chance that you've played
basketball I mean it's like when you're
literally younger high school or college
not like and then something like if
you're at seven feet then there's like a
like a 90 chance yeah like because
they'll just they'll just hire you like
you're tall we don't care if you're not
a player they'll literally fist fight
each other to get you to sign you know
the agents let's jump to the other side
of the world and talk news we have the
story from the defense post U.S
dispatches warships after Chinese
Russian vessels Patrol near Alaska you
know with a lot of people being like why
are you talking about Megan Rapinoe and
cultural stuff we got real news here
the US Navy deployed four destroyers
after detecting Chinese and Russian
vessels conducting joint patrols at the
coast of Alaska Alaska Republican
Senators Dan Sullivan and Lisa murkowski
revealed in a statement that at least 11
Russian and Chinese ships sailed close
to the Aleutian Islands in the northern
U.S last week this prompted the U.S
military to deploy four destroyers and a
p-8 Poseidon Maritime Patrol aircraft to
Shadow the vessels Rakowski explained
the incident served as a stark reminder
of Alaska's proximity to both Beijing
and Moscow incursions like this are why
we are working so hard to secure funding
and resources to expand our military's
capacity and capabilities in Alaska and
why our colleagues must join join us in
supporting those Investments well I got
bad news for you your woke military is
unappealing people don't want to be
involved in it and so the best you can
probably hope for is automation
unfortunately
or draft
no I don't think the draft's gonna work
the draft would just rip this country
and rip this country to shreds well I I
hope you're right I think if people were
being threatened with prison they'd have
to make that decision yeah yeah it'd be
crazier than uh than than people realize
man I feel like a draft isn't a
realistic
um possibility until they actually uh
like until there's actually some kind of
combat like where you have yeah but the
American dudes getting into gunfights
I'm not just talking about like you know
how easy it is to false flag the people
into well yeah yeah but I mean I'm I'm
just saying that like I'm not saying
that that it's out of the question I'm
just saying that I think there are
things that have to happen before that I
agree with you that becomes a thing
especially if they were to announce it
tomorrow there would be absolute uproar
but if they were to announce it after
allegedly no you know no nope okay later
on come on dude name a scenario in which
the left and the right unify
give me a second you're gonna have to
think hard on this one because I don't
see any circumstance let's say Vladimir
Putin goes on TV and says fires in his
house and then he hits a red button and
a nuke flies half the country goes this
is Joe Biden's fault you did this it's
your fault the other half says we need
to rally the troops and go fight against
Russia no no unification and then if Joe
Biden calls for the draft people are
going to actively be like I have this
scenario it's been it's been fomenting
for quite some time actually because the
GOP and their voters have been convinced
that the CCP is their archenemy so you
have some sort of leak that comes out
about the Wuhan Institute of virology
and the origin story there and and it's
now proven quote unquote simultaneously
Putin nukes Kiev
now you have the Catalyst uh from both
sides to be furious and accept it I'm
just a double a double false flag at
once come on I I don't think you will
get come on man I don't think you will
get you can maybe get a small portion of
conservatives but nobody's fighting for
Joe Biden you know why because Russia
could fire a nuke and China could admit
to the Wuhan lab leak and then Joe
Biden's gonna come out and be like we
need all of you to come together and and
and fight for this cause and
conservative conservatives are going to
say you actively support pedophiles and
I'm not talking about weird conspiracy
theories I'm talking about these books
in schools I'm talking about the groomer
events that these people are putting on
it doesn't matter what happens I can't
imagine a conservative being like you
know I know that Biden sniffs kids and I
know that the left actively supports
these sexually graphic books being given
to Children I'm gonna fight for those
people right not gonna happen well I
mean yeah I guess it would it would
require it would require loss of life
unfortunately I think it would be a
Pearl Harbor 911 type event I I you
don't think that would go absolutely not
wow people thought kovid would unite
this country yeah that that this massive
threat
in the first 60 days we were pretty
United in horror
yeah but we were not United in our
efforts together you had you had you had
the first the right was like everyone
should wear a mask and the left was like
No And then fauci comes out saying don't
wear masks and then all of a sudden a
few months later it switches like
there's no there's no unification of
this yeah well and if they were to if
they were to bomb yeah you're right I
probably wouldn't be that upset
depending on where it landed if if
another Pearl Harbor happened right now
there would probably be riots against
Joe Biden for having caused the
escalation by funding war in Ukraine see
that's interesting you say that because
I'm not at all convinced that the right
wing is capable of actually rioting like
January 6 was as close as they got and
that was pretty tepid no I I agree let's
let's let's break it down by actual how
things go
the US government then calls in a draft
of some sort right and then you get
massive conflict with people resisting
and rejecting police are going to be
split in half they're I mean cops are
already starting with a bunch of vote
policies but let's just put it simply
that if anything happened to this
country that resulted in hard military
action there would be
it would be Bedlam yeah you're not going
to get conservatives being like this is
the one issue where we've decided to
stand and salute Joe Biden never gonna
happen Okay especially when you look at
69 of Republicans believing that Biden
is illegitimate they will never salute
that man under any circumstances well
let me let me say one you make me more
hopeful and two uh to all of the
conservative listeners and viewers out
there I hope you're taking this to heart
if there is a draft for an immoral war
that is unjustified you have every Duty
not to go
they're talking about it now I'm sure
the op-eds are popping up saying it's
time for a job and it's because look
when I talk to people who have resigned
their commissions or who are saying like
one of my one of my four years are up
I'm gone
they're blaming wokeness Yep they're
saying that these these policies are the
antithesis of what I'm what I wanted to
fight for and now I'm disgusted one guy
told me he wanted to be a careerist and
now he's resigning his commission and
he's leaving
there I don't see anything that's going
to make people on the right agree with
this yeah
what kind of uh military conflict do you
guys expect to see in uh well the South
Asian Sea right now several American
ships you know outside of Korea in
Australia take a look at this they're
doing nothing yeah they dispatched
warships over the aleutians people need
to understand we're not talking about
the main body of Alaska we're talking
about the Illusions and if you come down
here to like ATU station
yo that's right next to like Russia yeah
it's equidistant between the two right
it's like
Alaska and Russia right next to each
other look at this you got St Lawrence
Island yo you're you're right there
and so if Russia and China are having
ships sail around the Bering Sea they're
going to be near the Aleutian Islands
where there's a whole lot of nothing now
to be fair but a lot of our crab from
Onalaska that's where they do that show
about crabbing and uh don't mess with
our crab Vlad I think it's on no where
is it I don't know where Onalaska is it
here where is it at well I could
probably just type it in but they're in
the Illusions they get crap they do they
do the crabbing stuff there
so this is a huge stretch of violence
that goes all the way towards Russia
very close to Japan even well I should
say very close but it's like look at
this like I'll go close I mean closer
than what California right
oh yeah substantially very closely
comparably yeah and I think the Bering
Strait is like like 50 miles or
something
I mean not not four and fakes right here
who owns that Russia from her house is
that Russia oh no it's Alaska diamond is
Alaska big diamond who owns big diamonds
I've heard like these islands you know
there'll be scientists who go back and
forth and it's kind of this weird
diplomatic relationship because they're
studying similar areas
look at this there's no reason for us to
be enemies with Russia I've been saying
this for years it's so it's so
ridiculous is this for real dimied
Island that's amazing it's beautiful wow
this podcast from there I feel like yeah
fun let's just uh let's just let's just
let's just go it's the winter for six
months I think that's one thing that the
American New Hampshire you can do it the
American people really aren't privy to
how much uh I don't know calm the both
the CCP as well as uh you know Putin has
has demonstrated towards the West given
How Deeply the West has gotten involved
in the war in Ukraine in terms of giving
them you know basically whatever
Weaponry they want there's now attacks
that are happening within within Russia
that are almost certainly from Weaponry
that's been provided by the West like
how I don't know how we can still
pretend as if this isn't antagonistic to
the point that they would be justified
in counter-attacking and I'm just so
grateful that it hasn't happened the U.S
commissioned their first Naval vessel in
Australia like last week and we're just
pretending like we did it for fun no way
we just like Sydney that much like no
obviously we did it for a reason there's
a reason why the first time we ever
commissioned a a naval ship outside of
the domestic Port was Australia it was
because recently China hello the first
wow yep you can read about it on Tim
cast news oh really I got I gotta read
that website it's a really good website
it's the best in my opinion that's what
I've been told yeah it's not as good as
Casper but it's pretty good well you
know they do different things to be fair
when was that when's that article from
I'll send it to you because I wrote it I
think it was like 48 hours I wrote it
that's why I know about it
well I just pull it up
it's from
I think a week ago maybe two weeks ago
at this point two weeks ago I thought
you said it was this week yeah it was
this Summer that was fake news
I was an inaccurate time is moving in a
crazy time is moving
um but it was it's the U.S USS Adelaide
it's named after a ship that they had
before at the Adelaide uh rescued I have
to read my own article again review the
facts but it was an Australian ship that
rescued an American ship and so they've
named it in honor of it uh but again
this press release came out from the dod
and they were like it's so fun we just
you know had this ship and it was made
in Alabama and we sent it to Australia
and anyways we commissioned it
everything's fine don't ask any
questions can I tangent briefly because
I'm I'm really Disturbed that there
hasn't because I'm thinking about China
right now and I'm just so Disturbed that
there hasn't been additional follow-up
by this current session uh Congressional
session from the GOP in terms of
figuring out the origin story of covid
like is there going to be anything do we
know Republicans don't do anything so I
have the story from San Diego Tribune it
says the San diego-based Canberra will
become the first U.S warship
commissioned in an Allied Natalie it was
Canberra right yeah I looked it up and
it's a combat ship this was uh end of
May so it's a couple months ago
was that a couple months ago that is
wild well I'm sorry I'm sorry no you are
right it was two weeks ago okay I was
gonna say there's no way I remember
uh the order was May the official
commissioning was July 22nd but the
story is from May yeah uh I sent you my
link to mine which was last week or two
weeks or whatever it was but I just
published the July 24th but it is
interesting that we have been talking
this was public the dod was saying we're
going to build a ship uh in a diplomat
from us uh state senator from Australia
came to Alabama and toured the facility
and now we're like oh yeah everything's
fine well what I find fascinating is
that it's so clear that the the Taiwan
issue is like the military industrial
complex of the of the United States
clearly wants this conflict to escalate
it whether or not they actually want
there to be a war or they just want to
be able to fill their coffers and and
create more Weaponry I don't know which
but what's interesting to me is that it
would be so beneficial to them to figure
out this Wuhan
piece of the you know in the ingredients
in terms of even if it were I mean if it
were true there'd be a lot of reason
that people would want to go to war with
China and if it's not true they would
probably want to flip it to propaganda
as the American people I think the
American people I think if if everything
gets out about what went on in the Wuhan
lab I don't think the United the
American people are going to be in any
position to demand the United States
going to war with China because I think
the United States had a lot to do with
actually doing that so the U.S blaming
China and being like oh we're going to
go ahead and and have a military action
against China when the United States was
was at the very least neck deep in
funding and directing was was there ever
a time in this country where you could
just turn the TV on watch football
pull the lever on your recliner crack a
beer
wings at your side and that was life
because we like to sometimes imagine
that's the case but I don't think that's
ever been the case maybe for like a
brief period in the 90s but there's
always been something going on to great
degrees of escalation and I want to
point out too
I think after the fall of the Soviet
Union we did have this period sort of
where we owned the world oh yeah
figuratively but you know kind of not if
you know what I mean no it was pretty
literal I mean from 91 on you have the
US dollar Reserve currency that's just
totally dominant you've also now crushed
your primary enemy they're gone there's
everybody else is still kind of
recovering from World War II or or
different uh conflicts and it's like
there was no one that was even close but
the problem is is that we squandered it
we had almost no national debt we have
the dollar Reserve uh you know position
on the global scale and an economy
that's absolutely crushing it uh and we
just we just blow it all for nothing and
and we look back on it it's like yeah we
were in this time of peace and
prosperity and we traded it all for what
like what did we get for this I'm not
surprised though I'm not necessarily we
have these stories about that people win
the lottery and what do they do they buy
golden statues of themselves right you
know it's just ridiculous it's improved
but for the longest time it's like
people would win the lottery and they
would just buy nonsense they would do
dumb things now they invested and they
you know they they set up trusts and
things they have good lawyers because
there was this big like public there was
stories about you know Night lottery
horror stories about people's lives were
ruined by the lottery and then they were
like you guys need to get advisors on
this but what happens when you get a
generation in this country that is is
gifted we are the children of the
greatest Generation the Boomers I'm not
saying the boomers are the greatest I'm
saying quite literally the greatest
Generation who fights in World War II we
have we have a nation of veterans people
who see combat and then we get this
period in the 90s where Millennials are
are growing up being handed
to a certain degree this easy life
then we get a bunch of crises we get the
Great Recession you get a lot of bad
things kovid Millennials have seen some
uh some bad stuff right the issue though
is
imagine growing up in the Great
Depression
when you're an adult you're grateful
you're like things are good no matter
how bad they get you grow up in the
depression then also you get World War
II and you're just like hey look man
I've seen some stuff right Millennials
were born into the most beautiful time
with parents being able to provide for
them in ways on average not everybody
but on average better than we've ever
seen
now they're all entitled they were
handed this gift they squandered it and
now they're entitled and angry well and
and
to in their defense there has been a lot
of mismanagement particularly through
their adult years that has been uh given
them given them serious reason to be
upset I mean from the 08 banking crisis
that was largely a Fed created Fiasco
but then the the lockdowns it's largely
well it's not entirely there's there was
still there was still Fanny and Freddie
that were packaging up uh you know
Triple B garbage and selling it off as
AAA so like there's you have a Fannie
and Freddie that was that was that's a
government entity I know I know but
that's not the Fed so okay okay all
right all right my my bad I
misunderstood you I thought it's almost
entirely a government phenomenon yes
okay everyone wants you to blame the
government
I mean he doesn't want you to come on
the show unless you're fully blaming the
governor but my friends we do have hope
one man stands out Above the Rest and
that man is Tucker Carlson
Joe Rogan says Tucker Carlson could win
the presidency in 2028 if the fired Fox
News house decides to run he has no
nonsense
why doesn't Joe have Tucker on his show
that would be that would be the biggest
I think I think it'd be the biggest
episode he's ever done
as as right as of right now it would be
the biggest podcast probably ever done
but then does Rogan have to go on
Tucker's show like who goes on who show
for actually well look hold on simulcast
it if I I think if right now Joe and
Tucker did an episode it would be
potentially the biggest podcast ever
done
but if Joe and Trump do a podcast it's
the biggest the biggest ever done it's
the most beautiful on top of that
Joe Trump and uh and Tucker Carlson on
the uh let's go on the culture dude oh
right over there yeah right but if you
got if you got Rogan Carlson and Trump
in one room for one like two or three
hour conversation be amazing it would
everyone in the world would be would be
listening in do that at Mar-A-Lago jeez
I would absolutely love that dude
awesome I don't think that Tucker has
any uh I don't think he's gonna run no
yeah why would you want to if you're him
like you get to do whatever you want
right now from Maine as far as I'm
concerned like you live your life you
get to have fun guests on you have
enormous influence but you don't have
the restrictions that the president does
or the responsibilities and if you think
Tucker's not paying attention to the
fact that you know they're trying to put
Trump in prison you know like he's a
father do you think that that he's going
to risk jail time to tell the truth to
the American people I don't think so and
I don't think that I think someone like
Tucker someone that is that much of an
outsider or at least treats The
Establishment and the specifically the
security uh and intelligence apparatus
that the government built
um that treats it with such disdain and
and speaks so frankly about it I think
that he would be a Target right away
and he would be targeted by the by the
that apparatus in a similar fashion to
the way that Trump was the big issue
though is
how much power Tucker would have to give
up to be president right he wouldn't
become more influential he wouldn't gain
more he would be less yeah it'd be a
different Power though I like it like
theoretically if if the figurehead
position of President actually has any
true power he would be able to remedy
some of the things that he's pointed out
with his journalism Trump shows that it
does
okay well I think for the most part they
expect presidents to be figureheads who
fall in line and just March in lockstep
you're allowed to affect domestic policy
negotiate amongst your party and but
don't screw with our plans
the fact that they are so desperately
trying to destroy Trump shows when
you're the president you have the power
yeah you can do that they may defy you
lie cheat and steal keep our troops
overseas but Donald Trump can go on
television and say I as the president
hereby order it be done and now they're
in trouble do you guys buy this Q Anon
thing that's happening what over the
past 48 hours there was this lady that
uh that puts out this video where she's
talking about how look I can't even
break it down it's so nutty sounding to
me but Trump then truth it whatever that
means and then like General whatever his
name is the guy that got thrown in jail
and then got released yeah Flynn now the
cue stuff is is nonsense but Trump trump
is pumping it though dude like it's he's
going hard on I've never seen anything
like that it's terrible but what are you
even talking about yeah what does she
say it's just it's a it's like a five
minute video she says a bunch of Bonkers
stuff I don't know if any of it's
legitimate guys I just can't introduce
somebody and then not explain it I can't
explain it it's it sounds totally crazy
when you get home they said all right
they said that it was like the the
United States is a corporation that's
bankrupt and Joe Biden's the president
of this bankrupt Corporation but he
Trump is still the actual president
when did he post this I think it was
yesterday I think no a couple days ago I
don't know it wasn't that long ago I'm
looking at his truth right now I'm going
back so I don't see anything what am I
missing what am I supposed to be looking
for there's this older lady that was on
the news in on Fox and you're no in
Europe
I don't know I I bro three days ago will
he retruth these maybe he deleted it I
don't know truth well these are retruths
he's retrothing old
truth again he should have made it Trump
trumpet and then he'd be returning
trumpet okay here's one day ago he says
rigged election blah blah blah
no look I'll just tell you that that the
US is a corporation stuff is it sounds
like nonsense to me it is nonsense
Rhonda said this is getting roasted
consistently no matter what he does or
says but he made a really good point
that I completely agree with on the 2020
election he said whoever puts their hand
in the Bible on the on January 20th one
I've been saying something very similar
Trump lost and they're like no dude no
dude I'm like yes he did because if he
won he'd be standing up there winning
this you know they weren't really yeah
what really Grands my gears is that
people think this is the one time the
one time there was malfeasance in an
election or something like ridiculous as
if the entirety of Elections have always
been some dirty underhanded scheme to
find loopholes to gain power always
perhaps the shadow campaign as described
by Time Magazine is the worst we've seen
it right Fair Point but yo
there's there's powerful Global uh
interests businesses big businesses
light bulb manufacturers you know
they're they're they're they're they're
they're trying to make LED lights I'm
half kidding they are but uh uh they're
a powerful powerful people in this
country who want to win to set law and
policy and they will do whatever they
can to get it
that means this idea that election day
is some holiday where we all smile walk
down to the voting booth wave and then
shake hands and say I'm going to cast my
vote for this person best of luck to
your candidate sir and then when the
news comes in saying well unfortunately
your candidate was shy by five votes
they go oh well gee golly I'll try
harder next time it's never been the
case people have always been doing Shady
stuff there's always been lies and
manipulation and they will do whatever
so that on the 20th they can stand
before this country and say they won
winning is not about this this hokey
vision of people casting a ballot well
it's War I think yeah well that's that's
the thing that's changed though in my
lifetime is that now when you lose a
federal election you feel like there's a
chance that you and your loved ones
might go to prison you know like and I'm
not even like being really hyperbolic
because had Trump won the January 6th
stuff probably you know even if it were
to have transpired it wouldn't have
ended up with people serving massive
massive time
um but that's really where we're at now
is like where depending on which side
when the other side feels as if they are
jeopardized and in the next existential
fashion and that's disturbing I think
maybe I found the video that you're
talking about this one from GB views
that's the one and what is it she like
will it play it's it's long dude don't
don't even it's it's long don't go there
and honestly it's 10 minutes long
there's no way we're gonna be able to
break that down
and it's like a screen grab of a Turk
someone from turkeys watching British
news but Trump puts it out it like he
retrothed it or whatever so I and he's
like he's like this is brilliant this
woman and I'm like this sounds this
sounds like the the rabbit with the
blonde hair no no no it's an older lady
that we're interviewing someone just
tweeted it at me okay I'm I'm gonna walk
definitely gonna watch it later yeah
she's gonna give you a full review
tomorrow we have the Super Chat from
Nick long he said Q is real look up x22
report for actual information on cue the
info y'all have is half truths why does
the media attack you so much think about
it I'll tell you why
um look the media is a lot of liars a
lot of activists and we still use a lot
of these sources we just have to fact
check them
yeah I'll tell you I'll tell you my
views on this stuff first a lot of it is
you know when this stuff first started
coming out and people were tweeting
about Q I was like I don't know you know
I'll take a look at what this is and
then sure enough there's a lot of
garbled gibberish nonsense and there
were a lot of like Nostradamus style
statements where it was like the Raven
has Has Lifted the suitcase has been
deposited Saturday comes and people
people would start taking these posts
and then dissecting what they could mean
with news reports and I'm like okay
y'all lost it lyrics then I actually met
some people
and I had a guy ask me if I would report
on Trump becoming president on March 7th
or whatever the date was and I was like
my friend that's not going to happen
right and he was like no man you got to
be the real news like this is true you
got to look it up and I was like I did
it's not true right and then sure enough
Trump did not become president well see
that that's the thing that that rubbeds
me the wrong way about that my aunt did
the same thing to me she's like she's
like you have a political podcast you
got to talk about this stuff I was like
I was like I think it's all nonsense I'm
sorry Auntie but it's just the history
of it is not good I had someone come to
me after the election 2020 and they said
why aren't you reporting on the fact
that Trump did win and that he's still
the president and that he's gonna be
brought in in March and Biden is not
really the Victor and I was like what
are you talking about what makes you
believe this and he was like you're
gonna look so dumb when Trump is
inaugurated on March and I was like
honestly rated in March I said if it's
if it's true that Trump that does happen
I didn't say anything about it so I
won't look one way or the other if I
come out right now and do a whole
segment about how it's not going to
happen sure maybe but I'm not even
talking about it at all because it's
nonsense right but but here's what
happened they said in March first it was
like it'll be the real inaugural
inauguration will be January then
February then March then they talk about
how it used to be that inauguration was
in March but after the Civil War it
changed and they shifted it back and
there's a reason for that you can read
the history it's about them trying to
stop short and lame duck sessions or
something like this then they were like
after March they were like well that's
because it's actually going to be in
June and I'm like oh and then June came
on nothing happened and they're like
exactly yeah but it's because my
favorite Conspiracy Theory with the Q
stuff
was that Joe Biden was actually already
arrested and that he was secretly
pretending to be president to Shield
Donald Trump because we were at war with
Russia
as opposed to being a doomsday cult
where you constantly uh extend the
calendar window by which your prediction
has to come true they are a hopium cult
where like the the the deadline by which
the good thing that's supposed to happen
that will never happen is extended 60
days every time it drives me nuts but
anyways Trump actually was like fully
acknowledging these insane ramblings of
this case and I was like I was like or
this is the reason I I brought it up to
Tim actually is because if all right so
here's the two options Trump is either a
a you know he's actually in on this Q
thing and it's real which I don't
believe at all or
he's lying to his supporters and and
leading them on with this nonsense which
is not a good thing or he's actually
duped by it
which is maybe the worst possible
outcome so like is there a good option
as to why Trump's doing this I know okay
so it's either blew it on or it's you
know 4chan just playing a fun game and I
don't I can't tell you what it is
that's why I say blue and on so well
blue and on is Democrats oh yeah blowing
on is like Democrats who believe in
Russia gate and all that nonsense and
they're like ah it's the same thing
right and it's it's
it's it it breaks my heart a little bit
that these people refuse to actually
recognize the world in front of them
thus the Deep State wins well that's why
I've always assumed that Q Anon was a
psychological operation because it
completely defend people during this
time where you would have expected them
to be absolutely out of their minds
Furious and they're like no no no
at the time when you needed activists to
be filing lawsuits to be showing up with
signs in front of courthouses making
demands for regisive grievances exactly
they actually all just stayed at the
computers and were like whoa exactly
I'll just sit here because it's all part
of like I trust the plan
trust the plan as it all gets Swept Away
not Donald Trump's facing
641 years in prison it's all part of the
plan well trust the plan everybody they
did say where we go when we we go all so
now they're all going to prison it's uh
I didn't think they I don't think they
thought it was going in that direction
though it's really it's crazy man yeah
Trump's now facing 641 years in prison
because all these people trusted the
plan it's unreal crazy seems like not a
great plan is being indicted it's part
of the plan yeah the Democrats plan dude
the whole plan was from the Democrats
the whole time
that's why I keep saying blue and on
because it's just that's what it is I
mean come on it's nice though because
now whenever you don't want to explain
your decisions to someone you say trust
the plan and they have to
yeah trust the plan the Deep State
whispered to president Trump you cannot
withstand the storm the president wished
whispered back I am the storm
I'm imagining Trump in an orange
jumpsuit in a prison somewhere
Whispering like I'm the storm
I know you've got a lot of Hope for him
in his second term theoretically if he
were to actually get through it and it's
actually a legitimate election all blah
blah but like if he's actually buying
this nonsense what what does that
portend for the conservatives moving
forward there's there's no such thing as
a quote-unquote legitimate election this
is what I always try to tell people
because they're like oh this wasn't fair
and you know whatever and I'm like dude
every election they do something to gain
an edge there it there there is no world
in which we all right here today say
hello everyone I would like to vote on
what we order for dinner I propose Pizza
how do you vote sir
pizza too okay we have two votes for
pizza and then we all sit down and we
count the ballots and we go wow Pizza
wins then we all high five that that's
never never happened
quite literally it's like hey everybody
I'm voting on whether or not we're gonna
have pizza and um I have these military
votes there's ten of them for pizza uh
your votes don't matter right there's
always been some weird nonsense yeah or
they go like someone goes out and goes
across the hall and then goes asks Brett
and Carter to vote for salad and then
they'll bring it in and say oh but they
work here too so their votes count then
all of a sudden a bunch of guys from
Home Depot show up and they're voting
for for you know uh I don't know
Home Depot
the refugees you don't understand
it's like we can talk about Donald Trump
in 2016 saying that there are a bunch of
illegal votes cast
and but nobody nobody said it was an
illegitimate election except for the
Democrats like I mean like the Trump
supporters were like we're happy Trump
won right there have always been issues
even Trump claimed there were issues in
2016. so this is just the game is dirty
it is it is a dirty dirty game and if
you get outplayed you lose yep
and it feels like the American people
have been outplayed for quite some time
oh absolutely tragically
absolutely
maybe that's the hardest thing about
Megan rapuno because we're like hey at
least our athletes should be good well
you you saw you saw when Roseanne was on
yeah it was incredible and she made a
bet with Michael malice that by the end
of the year there would be military
tribunals I know and I'm just this is
part of all she is my aunt She's My
Crazy Aunt at home that's just like she
just buys all the crazy nonsense I love
them though the part of me thinks
Roseanne is intentionally
like poking and being you know Silly she
seems sincere about that yeah but she
said a bunch of like she said a bunch of
things recently as a comedian that are
like shocking and confusing and she said
conscious she said contradictory things
too and it's like I kind of feel like
she's
she's being funny she's being a
character she's putting on this you know
I'm open to all possible hey look if if
she if she really does believe it she
made a bet with Michael malice I just
gotta I have to take this opportunity to
condemn Michael malice for yes for
trying to take money from my sweet Crazy
Aunt Roseanne how dare you about malice
well we're a monster she's just she just
has crazy cue drop brain and you're
trying to take thousands of dollars off
of her not cool man she also there
wouldn't be an election in 2024 so we
got a bet for this year and a bet for
next year but my my point in response to
the election thing is if Donald Trump is
removed from the ballot
is it then a legitimate election because
if he's the clear FrontRunner in the
primaries the Democrats pull some Court
legal trick to get his name ripped off
the belts then there's no real
opportunity for an election if you can't
even vote for the guy you want Oh bro if
that if it goes that route like
just batting down the hatches like it's
over I don't even know even if like I've
been listening I listened to this uh
this guy uh what if all this you I think
you Serge you tell me about him and uh
he put out a uh a video today talking
about
um
basically maybe it wasn't today a couple
days ago but it was it was about
feminism about young men and the polls
that say young young men are leaning
extremely conservative nowadays oh yeah
yeah three days ago yeah and what that
means for for the future and stuff if
you have women that don't look to get
married and you don't have a Revival of
of
um
a Revival of conservative values or or
you know Traditional Values among women
the same way that you do among young men
because if you look at that that graph
or whatever the the the they were they
had never been further apart men and
women their political leanings women are
voting women exclusively young unmarried
women are keeping the Democrat Party
alive every other it seems like every
other uh um group is is actually voting
for for or is at least not strongly
Democrat and it's at the end of the day
that if if men can't make families then
they make more no this this my
prediction here whatever that does
happen the Democrats done
the Democrats are done with this metric
showing that 12th grade boys are like
what is it like four to one conservative
and the women are like uh I think it's
three to one liberal those young women
will be conservative in five years I
don't think there's any conflict between
what you're saying what I'm saying
because you're saying the Democrats are
done probably because those women in
five years will be conservative I'm
saying that young men that don't get
that don't have the option of having not
starting families they won't end up with
families because if you look at the
numbers the numbers that that that the
guy that uh that this video presented
don't line up with that at all but well
they're gonna have families here's to
tell you why it's because men are object
oriented and women are subject oriented
and the young women who have strong
emotional desires for uh for socializing
men with men are going to start to be
pulled in the men's Direction not the
other way around isn't the problem that
this I mean you're saying five years but
that's basically their senior year of
college and the the reason and that
women are predominantly Democrat voters
is because they're also the predominant
College attendees and they're going to
be saddled with massive debt and unable
to live on their own so they're gonna
have to appeal to the conservative uh
you know construction worker it's not
they have to it's that women are going
to go out what what is what are the
tropes and and the stereotypes women uh
uh talk about men men talk about things
if that is only a tendency that women
are more interested in social
interactions between men and women and
men are interested in their goals or
whatever women will be seeking ways to
interact with men like
I don't see a there there's going to be
a scenario and we've we already see it
now in the data where you have young men
who are Democrats and it appears to be
because they're what biologists call and
again this is a legitimate literal term
sneaky this is the actual
biological term
uh biologists use the term sneaky
to describe a situation where you say
you have the the alpha male oh I've
heard about this yeah the sneaky
sneaks in the middle of the night bangs
the women to procreate so it's so you
have the the man who bangs on his chest
and Roar and lifts muscles and attracts
women and then you have the sneaky
who sneaks in and weasels his way
yes
that's the male thing right right but
with young men skewing more and more
conservative if women want to have these
social interactions with men they're
going to have to meet men where they're
going there's there's not enough women
that want to so okay no yeah I I don't
think you understand what they want the
fact that we can see social Contagion on
on Instagram young women developing
Tourette's it's not an issue of of women
coming together and having a women's
meeting and being like we're not going
to listen to these men it's that they're
going to be talking about the guys they
like and all the guys are going to be
conservative so something's going to
have to break where the women are
talking to each other and they're going
to be like but he's not woke and there's
no other guy you you either you the all
the guys at school the athletes the
musicians the rock stars the writers
they're all skewing conservative any
woman who wants to date a guy is going
to be dating a guy who's moderate to
conservative and then they're gonna have
to start listening to these other women
who are going to be saying things like
Well you're dating this far right guy
and they'll be like who are you dating
nobody yeah not a single person I think
it's going to depend on if they want to
have families because I don't even I've
never really understood why you would
date a left-leaning man when it comes to
starting a family because so so rarely
are they actually on that path anyways
so I'm I'm I'm surprised this trend
hasn't already reverted where women as
they get into their late 20s early 30s
they start to pursue more conservative
Leading Men because they want to have
kids women become more conservative
after they get married and I think
culturally right now marriage is not a
priority for men or women I think that
there are a lot of women who should
prioritize but I think in both Spears
there are men who are like I'm
conservative but I'm gonna put off
getting married or whatever else it's
it's true in both spaces both men and
women should want marriage for it to
become a more noteworthy Trend I will
say uh you have to remember that after
2016 there are all these uh feminist
journalists who came out saying I can
remember one article specifically being
like I keep sleeping with this Trump
supporter and I I can't stop like he's
everything I hate but I I really want to
sleep with him so like there is
obviously something too yeah yeah that
happens to all the time can't stop
sleeping anyways I can't stop sleeping
with Trump supporters male Trump
supporters I wish I could stop but I
can't no but it's interesting uh be
because I think there is a desire among
women for traditionally male attributes
in a way that's undeniable so the
majority of women in every age group
every generation right now identifies as
a feminist right it's something like
between 53 to 67 in every generation but
obviously that's not true for the number
of men who identifies a male feminist so
how do they partner up it either means
that they're in their feminist in name
only they're willing to give it up and
when they get married they again lots of
couples become more most women are if I
understand correctly most women are not
super committed to politics like they're
more interested in like their life I
think there's a huge Spectrum right and
you know I think women do talk about men
they also just generally are more
interested in social dynamics and that
is one of the benefits of having women
in society is they're going to tell you
who's fighting and all sorts of things I
mean Remember The Stereotype of the
powerful businessman whose wife then
throws a dinner party where he networks
with whoever right like there is a there
is a a positive symbiotic relationship
between men and women in traditionally
gendered roles I think the the trend of
teenage boys becoming more conservative
will inspire some teenage girls to be
more openly conservative but I think
generally it's always on the cusp anyway
so there's population collapse coming
from multiple countries it's happening
in the west we've got like what 1.2 or
something like that kids per couple per
per person there's a population collapse
coming there's a significant uh portion
of women that don't ever want to get
married the P the people that but men
too I mean I think it's not but it's not
it's not as it's not as pronounced with
men because men don't like women look
for like specific things in guys guys
look for women like it's real different
what women are looking for in a man no
incentive for men to get married right
now really like you could partner up
with girl you could have her move in you
could pay for early you guys could have
a bunch of kids like the for women they
don't want to get married because they
think in some way they'll be oppressed
but actually there are all sorts of
Legal Financial reasons for women to
want marriage so it's complete
brainwashing so unless men are also
loudly speaking about why marriage is
good we'll just continue down this trend
of girls being like ah I don't think so
except for this new cultural element
which is that men are starting to be
more openly conservative at a younger
age well this this is a bit of a tangent
but I think it's important to to
consider you know Japan and there's
other nations where you've seen these
kind of population uh implosions China
too to a certain extent
um and it it's quite evident that the
United States is on in that as well as
most of you know Western Europe and
things like that
um I'm not at all convinced that we
aren't going to just kind of spiral into
that like I know uh that was the point
that I was that I was trying to make in
the first place is like because of the
way that that the the population
or the marriage statistics and stuff are
and there the the number of young men
that are not getting married and that
aren't going to be if you have young men
that don't get into families they get
into fights they get into trouble they
and that means they get into war and
that is something that has happened
throughout history and as as long as we
have young men that are not married and
can't meet women they have no reason to
settle down like what like you're saying
men don't have a reason to settle down
women give men the reason to chill out
because they want you know they want to
hang out with the girl they want to get
laid they want to hang out with their
wife whatever if they don't have that
reason they want to get out go out and
get Buck Wild
Side my point is that we are seeing this
data showing 12th grade boys are skewing
conservative and 12th grade girls are
skewing liberal and give that a few
years and the women are going to drift
towards the men not the other way around
it's possible Dave Smith has a great bit
which I will not do justice so I will
not even try uh but it was about how his
wife uh he she finds him in this alley
he's an alley cat and then she just lays
out milk and slowly lures him into the
house and I I feel like that's the the
problem is that when you have a more uh
you know leftist leaning woman they're
not going to put out that saucer of milk
because they're not interested in
attracting The Alley Cat male so like
when will that Trend change where the
women actually want to settle down and
I'm not sure that it will happen
to it than Society I think I think the
issue is this young men are object
oriented typically young women are
subject oriented typically that means if
a guy is a skateboarder he's going to
find himself hanging out with a bunch of
other guys skateboarding they are going
to be so his draw will be I want to go
skateboard with my friends
the young women their draw will be I
want to engage in socialization the men
are off skateboarding all with each
other sharing ideas making jokes being
offensive and being guys they're skewing
conservative they're listening to Jordan
Peterson they're listening to Andrew
Tate
one day at the park you've got a handful
of young guys skateboarding and a
handful of girls and those guys are like
hey these girls are pretty attractive
then the girls are going to reach some
kind of impasse with wow they like one
of those guys was playing an Andrew Tate
video we can't be associated with that
one of those women is going to be like I
kind of want to be hanging out with some
of these guys like I wanna I wanna like
we are social creatures more so than the
men are that means that there's going to
be competition among the women for so in
terms of socializing
to
go to these guys this is why like you
mentioned women become more conservative
when they get married that same poll I
think is going to happen and it's going
to realign young women towards more
modern conservative views from your lips
to God's ears man I don't know I think
when men and women interact especially
when they get married a lot of stuff
changes I mean studies bear out that uh
when couples get when couples have kids
they become more religious they tend to
attend churches more regularly there are
stuff that I think when you are a single
individual you don't prioritize in your
life because you know you're you're not
as important right your goals are just
different but as soon as you start
having this intense bond to someone else
through marriage and having children
with them everything shifts and so it's
just interesting that it's it's reaching
teenage boys and the decisions that they
make like you're saying by the time
they're seeing string College will be
very different than the two generations
before them yeah well and I and I think
my hope is that there there's it's quite
evident to me that there's a lot of
sadness and loneliness and
purposelessness and rudderlessness I'm
gonna stop saying this this is too hard
um amongst young people in this country
and like so much of our I mean just
empirically speaking there's so much of
what humans uh passion and purpose is on
existing is to be a parent to be a
father a mother
um and I just pray that like even though
I'm not religious I still I pray that
people will find that pathway to purpose
once again because it's it's quite clear
to me that there's a lot of people that
are are desperate yeah and I think the
purpose of speeds are uh our culture
self-obsession right this if you have
nothing to do or work on you tend to
just be completely obsessed with
whatever's happening inside your own
head yes which narcissistic egotistical
and and also psychotic I mean you know
you basically go crazy right and you
start to think like well everyone seems
happier than I am and it's because
you're not living for fulfillment I mean
the things that you the the emotional
gratification occasion sorry I can't
talk at all the emotional gratification
of achieving something is so important
to the human psyche that if we live in a
culture where you just get handed a lot
of stuff to Tim's earlier Point uh then
you never feel that true satisfaction
it's very difficult to find direction
for your life because you can't find
something that may that makes you feel
fulfilled and largely because there's no
self-sacrifice involved in any of their
behaviors and if you're not ever doing
anything for others it's very hard to
feel any sense of value I think so I
guess we'll see the one thing I think
that matters too is we bring up quite a
bit that um in the 2000s conservatives
just had more kids so we're seeing this
trend very likely due to just sheer
numbers yeah well and that and that
Trend will maintain if not grow
absolutely the the Liberals are more
likely to abort their kids and sterilize
their kids right that's it you can't
beat math baby no no that trajectory is
going to uh go parabolic potentially
I've seen too many of these stories
right there's and I know the feminists
are going to lose their minds over this
there's the New York Post where the
woman was like I'm struggling to find a
man who makes the same amount of money
as me I'm telling you like we see these
Trends in data doesn't mean it's
absolute doesn't mean I'm correct of
course 100 I'm saying I see this as a
possibility you've got these women who
are trying to be with men but it's like
oh
you're 35 you make 60 000 a year and
you're trying to date a 35 year old guy
who makes 60 000 a year guess what that
35 year old guy who makes 60k a year he
could be doing better but he's dating a
28 year old hmm he's got money he's got
an apartment he's not why would he date
you and that and and that bothers
feminists quite a bit but that's the New
York Post reporting that's it that's
right now that's what happens of course
I mean John Peterson talks about the IQ
scale for women right like it's much
harder for high IQ women to find
partners because they need someone who's
smarter than them like I've always said
it would be difficult for me to date
someone who is less conservative than I
am because it would feel like a it would
feel like a mismatch right why is it
harder for women to find if they're high
IQ to find a high IQ made I don't
understand
yeah there's less men that are
intelligent no no no for them to choose
from if you have to be sure it Narrows
their it there's not as many yeah yeah
okay okay don't exist so so this is the
thing like a really dumb woman
she's got lots of options but it's easy
to date up and and you know that's
interesting thing like how do you
describe it for men women want to date
up that's what they call it right
someone who is more powerful more
attractive wealthier more capable
Crossing up minimum day of Crossing down
men as a cross and down men will date
across and and so they don't want a
woman that's smarter not well not just
smarter but but social Mobility yeah
stuff like that so like if if you're
like if you start date if you get with a
girl and she doesn't make more money
than you one of the best predictors
about or one of the high predictors of
divorces if she does make more money
because she starts making more money
she'll probably you're probably gonna
end up in a divorce the left takes the
data on this but yeah because it's
reality in there because they're coming
the Communists don't want to accept that
men are attracted to appearance and
women I should say this that men have a
tendency to be attracted towards
appearance to a great degree and women
have a tendency to be attracted towards
power and status to a great degree which
boils down to men are attracted to women
that look able to produce Offspring and
women are attracted to men that look
able to protect them it's that so if
you're rich you got a lot of money you
have resources you can protect women
you're big and strong you can you're
physically fit you can protect women
wait so you're telling me that the
immutable laws of human nature remain
intact feel you know let's talk about
men
is in vaginas you know who's got what
you know because it you know it's
getting confusing these days apparently
well I I was just thinking about it
because I was like have I dated a woman
that's smarter than me and but then I'm
like am I am I too narcissistic to even
acknowledge if I've dated a woman that's
smarter than me have you ever have you
ever had an attraction to someone who
sometimes feels like wearing pants
foreign
yes that makes you bisexual
no no no men wear pants when we wear
dresses oh and if if a woman sometimes
decides to wear pants pants then she
said pants she's non-binary
all right because I'm questioning my
wardrobe tonight yeah well uh Hannah
Claire over here is a guy oh interesting
one of the boys
that's right oh my goodness I think one
time when your podcast was Sheamus and
he was like yeah I don't think women
should be able to wear dresses but I
realize I've sort of lost this battle
dresses I should be it shouldn't be
shouldn't be able to wear pants Sheamus
said that of course
quick shot at the same as I will be on
his show on Thursday wait he doesn't
want women wearing pants yeah but he
realizes on that one he's like as soon
as you put that so so if if the argument
is that social constructs define whether
you're a man or a woman that's literally
the point yeah so if like someone who
was male decides one day to wear a dress
if you're straight you should be
attracted to them that's the argument we
get from the left but but it literally
is like when we had Lance on the show he
outright said that I know dude the guy
outright said that if a guy sleeps with
a manly looking woman he's gay and I'm
like that's really mean to that poor
woman like to Barack Obama
I am so happy that Lance decided to come
and join oh me too even though even
though I feel like I had a two-hour long
aneurysm I was like
I want you to imagine the scenario and
maybe maybe we should get I'll ask
Robbie if he wants to do this my buddy
Robbie and Ty's comedian yeah go to uh
go to DC go to downtown DC and man on
the street wait till you see a guy and a
woman who are clearly married but the
woman is manly and then stop them and
tell the man he's gay because his wife
looks like a man and see how that goes
down
yo I don't think it's gonna go well
that'd be fire man on the street footage
though that'd be amazing just going
around be like you got a homely male
wife no no like your your wife is
wearing pants and looks like a guy so
you're gay
it's gonna be like don't talk about my
wife that way oh goodness but hey you
know he's gonna be like why are you a
bigot
as he tries to fist fight him you just
go big it big it what relax it's a good
thing kids love that stuff these days
it's like the meanest thing I've ever
heard someone that's a great idea
honestly he was saying Ryan long should
be doing that right now he told us that
if there is a man who is like you know
six three and ripped bald Burly super
strong and he's dating another man who
is like 5'5 and effeminate he's straight
and I'm like dude dispense all logic go
to go to Boys Town in Chicago and find a
bear in a twink and tell him he's
actually straight they're a straight
couple and they're gonna look at you and
they're gonna think you're nuts granted
in that scenario they're probably not
going to hit you like telling a guy's
wife looks like a man the definition of
queer according to queer theorists is an
identity without an Essence so it's like
there is no actual straight or gay it's
just kind of
moving around and they just it's Tran
they're gearing us up for transhumanism
whether it's intentional or not uh well
yeah I mean that's coming right because
all of these things are grains of sand
that when slide together like no no
they're bits of liquid metal that are
sliding together like the T-1000 or it
was the T2000 which was which was the
liquidity 1000 was the liquid one yeah
okay that one all coming together and
then when they do it's transhumanism so
it's like this idea that you can be
anything that your identity is
meaningless you can change your body
then you get neural link you get AI the
end result is whatever conscious entity
that is born within you your soul or
what I'm gonna call it is an amorphous
meaningless blob of Life mass and that
your body is nothing and they can
transfer it to a robot and then you're a
microwave
future where transhumanism is is
absolute and we can download your brain
there'd be like we have a job for you
microwaving food and we're gonna put
your brain in the microwave so that you
can provide for people better meals see
that more houses I'm the guy that thinks
that the there is no separating you from
your brain like so maybe they'll put
maybe they'll put your brain in like a
tank on top of the microwave I mean like
the the character from Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles with the brains in his
stomach sorry I kind of disagree with
you but for the last couple of years
I've been thinking maybe there is a way
to separate the brain from the body
no no I'm not not for the brain from the
body the the the the the experience of
being you cannot be separated from the
brain so like people that say oh you can
download your Consciousness into a
computer I don't believe that there's a
funny there's a funny meme where it's
it's a picture of a guy smiling and it
says you in hell looking up at the
Clones AI robot version of you that is a
facsimile of your Consciousness yeah I
think that's the the disturbing thing
about this is that as people become more
more kind of sad and desperate and incel
e that's the word
um that if you have these things that
are on offer it's not going to be a
force thing like a lot of people are
always afraid like oh the government's
gonna mandate this that's like no I
think people are going to do it
voluntarily people people people have
voluntarily decided oh exactly monitored
constantly in their location everything
they say like not only have they decided
that they're going to do it but they pay
a monthly fee for it yeah so and yes and
we're we're all guilty of the same but
we're sitting here talking about them
like it's like it's not us
when they when we're saying them this is
them right here this is them we're gonna
go to super chats if you haven't already
but you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends if you really do like
it word of mouth is the best way to help
podcasts grow and um head over to
timcast.com click join us become a
member we're gonna have a members only
uncensored show coming up at about 10
p.m and we'll read what you're where
super chats are and your comments on
this crazy world
all right Nate
how do you pronounce this uh
spierka says
whatever happened with that Yingling
beer and the drag promotion or was that
just a misunderstanding uh good things
happened Yingling sponsored the venue
that was putting on a all and all ages
drag show Yingling responded saying we
just sponsored The Venue at the events
however we reached out to them and said
this event should be 18 and up only and
they agreed thank you and we were all
like that's really really awesome Wow
have your drag show man go party but
it's not for kids Yingling agreed the
vendor the event agreed and that was the
end of it
that we all moved on we're all big fans
of Yingling there you go except for the
alcohol part
y'all can drink beer all day and night
it's an American Pastime actually a
human Pastime but not for me
not for me you know Trump's never had
alcohol never had a drop yeah no drugs
no alcohol no smoking even right and his
kids don't drink when they're around him
from what I've heard wow that's kind of
crazy
never never had any alcohol I get a
quick shout out to Elon Musk and ex who
just sent me 400 bucks for my uh my
Twitter what my Twitter ad Revenue
shares you got money yeah dude how do I
say that I just got a notification I
don't know it just came in randomly I
just want to be able to get that to do
that like I haven't been able to get
like they haven't even give you the
approval no come on Twitter with my
massive Twitter following well where did
you get the notification just popped up
on X I think it was
I got it last time and I wanted I just
want to see how I can how it Compares X
monetization you got paid you got paid
oh okay I wonder if I got paid I was
interesting Elon sent this to you when
you're on this show I know look at this
feature look at you Elan you clever
little marketing Guru you hairline
regrets I haven't gotten any emails
though don't say anything rude to Elon
dude when yours comes through it's gonna
be it's a big family no I got I got 6K
last time so if you know if if that was
based on three months then it would be
two yeah but the first time what
happened was I was just I was sitting
here working and I clicked over to X
Twitter at the time and that thing just
popped up saying you got paid and now
like obviously you got the same thing
yeah no but on Twitter it wasn't an
email or anything oh interesting
well I just got approved for
subscriptions like a week ago so I'm
sorry this was an interruption that was
totally oh okay I wonder if that's some
free x promotion which is still Twitter
to me it will always be Twitter to me
because if it did just if because
everyone got at the same time and if
they did just do the notifications I
would like to tell people like what
we're looking at but I don't know how to
even
I just got an email I don't know if it's
if it's everything like I think because
I I was not approved in the early wave
mine maybe do you think it's yours is
like delayed you're getting one yeah and
I don't think mine's backdated because I
do pretty good uh transaction and I it's
not a crazy amount of money so obviously
it wasn't a six-month payout it was just
a month I guess it's just so you would
say it on the show I think so I think
when did you sign up for subscriptions
just a week ago so I won I I should have
got something for the beginning of the
month though right is that is that what
is I wonder if anyone else noticed
anything don't know yeah I'm just happy
that Josie shout out to redhead
libertarian she's crushed it on Twitter
about to hit half a million all right on
maybe I got something on uh
no YouTube emailed me
oh wait wait what did I I think I got
something from Max
nope nothing no wait wait here it is oh
it's from Elon
him personally Tim you suck oh whoa I'm
kidding Elon unbelievable
all right Frey Kane says funny that g
Prime's comic of Megan rapping over
Sweden became relevant again that is
that is uh quite the the equate humorous
purple says 11 warships from Russia and
China near Alaska
yeah some like that something like that
how many of U.S ships are in Asia right
now see we never report that do we
because they're always over there we
have we have two in South Korea right
now we just sent them of course I'm
gonna say last week but as we now know I
I've mixed up the last three weeks we
have them like in the Baltic in the
Atlantic and everywhere and they're like
there's a a record increase of the
Russians actually sailing anywhere near
us when we're constantly over in their
business Noah Sanders says I'm assuming
Cassandra is already reaching out to Neo
or his people to get him on IRL or the
culture War I'd love to hear him
elaborate the culture war is the best
spot for him the thing about IRL is uh
we started the culture War because there
are a lot of guests that come on the
show
but they don't know what this show is
and it's the weirdest thing when we get
requests from people where it's like I'd
really love to come on Tim cast IRL and
I'm like it's a topical news program
where we discuss the news of the day and
they're like oh I don't read the news at
all I'm a research scientist who studies
you know graphene and I'm like okay well
like that's cool but you know we need a
migration yeah because because we've had
guests on the show many people know this
that they don't talk at all and then
people like why aren't you letting the
guests speak it's like dude there's no
letting anyone speak you speak or you
don't yep and so we have people on it's
like my job is I produce you know uh
potato chips and then we're talking
about Joe Biden being impeached or
something and they're just sitting there
like I learned I learned that the hard
way the first time I was on was almost
two years ago now and I was just sat
there silent for the first half an hour
I was like they're gonna kick it to me
eventually no you just have to get in
there get
we do try to make like some eye contact
be like right you're good but like I
mean we've had we've had like Sheamus
you tried really hard with a lot of
people he'd be like there are people
where it's they just don't talk they're
not as good at that too yeah he tends to
go and ask direct questions I noticed
that I would love it though if neocate
you're like it's a topical newspaper and
he was like yes great I've been reading
the news I'm prepared that'd be amazing
here's a good one easy doll uh Dog Log
says while joining the stream I got a
Joe Biden campaign ad using Marjorie
Taylor green they made it seem MTG is on
their side WTF is this money for me baby
that's what it is also I I love I love
um political season is like our Olympics
yeah like presidential election season
because Revenue skyrockets viewership
skyrockets everybody's paying attention
and we're like oh everyone's back in The
Fray waiting for politics and then the
year after the presidential election is
the apocalypse where it's like worse
than it's ever been
but yo like we made it was crazy how
much money we're making in 2020.
it's it's insane because uh you had all
these crazy people dumping like the most
insane amounts of money plus you had the
lockdown so people were the viewership
was through the roof it was just it was
a crazy time crazy crazy time
uh what was uh Dallas Smith says it's
embarrassing to admit Megan was a fellow
athlete I went to Portland State for
football but their indoctrination
attempt failed
no good for you dude good for you
Joseph Kush says please do another
Pelosi impression
Donald Trump is the worst presidency we
need to vote him out
that's my Nancy Pelosi it's
intentionally disrespectful to her
I love though I love the way it sounds
like you really you really nailed it up
he nailed the holding my dentures in my
mouth while I'm trying to articulate
sound that Nancy Pelosi's known well but
instead of it being Trump it's like the
precious is replaced with Trump
incredible precious yeah because it
sounds a little bit he tried to
overthrow this country it totally sounds
like your teeth are gonna fall out that
is spectacular
no I didn't
all right where are we at
verculos alcorland says one of the men
who found who funded sound of Freedom
Fabian Marta was arrested for child
kidnapping that's fake news yeah it's
it's it's an exaggeration and when it
says like funded like he gave like 500
bucks to the to the GoFundMe or
something like that no
media raising us think about it but
apparently he was just landlord to a
woman who took her kid in custody in a
custody dispute funny that yeah dude and
it was like 600 or some some crazy high
amount of people that were actually
donating to that campaign and they they
like reverse searched all of them to
find any of them that had a criminal
history and that was the worst thing
they could come up with is it basically
a landlord who got dragged into a yeah
like obviously a good guy and they're
trying to trying to point there or paint
the entire that's a very desperate
attempt it's but it's disturbing yeah
like what are you doing man my God and
he's just an average guy like oh also
like so terrible people Pro
yeah I don't know all right raybert
raybert G stanbert JR says Tim did you
hear about the h3h3 podcast with jenk's
nephew yeah actual Justice Ware did a
pretty good breakdown of it jenk's
nephew made Ethan look normal with his
unhinged takes on IPS and government
subsidizing artists but they do that
show all the time it's called leftovers
out of three it's like a normal thing
they do yeah yeah
it was he was he's referring to to
um shank's nephew's uh terrible take
yeah yeah he did make L3 look really
normal why would you say because it was
about um because so Hassan just sits
around and just lets other people's
content play and once in a while he'll
talk about it yeah and so he essentially
is stealing content and h3h3 uh Ethan
was complaining about that and someone
else doing it and Hassan sitting it's
it's almost like Ethan was complaining
about what Hassan does and didn't really
realize that that's what Hassan does
because he was complaining about someone
else doing it and Hassan's sitting there
trying to defend it and he's like you
think that's okay how can you think it's
and it's funny because it's not sitting
there like kind of Shifting he's like
well you know it's okay and blah blah I
don't care so it was just it was a it
was it was funny to watch Hassan be so
uncomfortable because Ethan was
critiquing what Hassan does but it was
in the context of critiquing someone
else so hmm well all right let's get
some more Super chats
Raymond g Stanley Junior says Tim it's
official I made the team and I'm honored
to be a part of it worry not folks the
timcast facilities are in the bestest of
the best hands everyone says so for the
line I deserve this
Raymond g Stanley Jr now officially
works for timcast and he's already
giving his money back to us talk about
dedication
facilities uh manager very cool yeah
we've like our AC has broken so many
times we're like we better just hire
some guy yeah he was like Hey I can fix
it and we're like all right you're hired
stoked yeah we have a tendency of hiring
super chatters
well we see their name over and over
again we know they like the show I'm not
paying attention
that's the secret to getting hired here
I guess we see your name often enough
that when the email comes in we're like
oh yeah it's that guy
oh sure you're hired it's like a very
weird form of an epidemic
well yeah you know it's like how else do
you get the attention it's hard we have
a sea of emails from all these people we
try to go through them and then we like
we've hired obviously we've hired most
of our people through normal normal I
didn't Super Chat just for reference
yeah she was nepotism yeah I was
actually actually I did I technically
did Super Chat oh you Fanboy he did
Super Chat I'm sitting at home and Tim's
like maybe we'll get someone to do this
hello it's me
yes like we we need people who are here
who can who can host a show if I'm ever
out or just who can add to the roster so
we have more people when people when
people aren't available and then Phil is
like I would like to come and I was like
oh yeah of course are you kidding yep
that's what we do we just you Super Chat
us and you're hired that's how it works
I guess
a green Clover says I'm disappointed you
all didn't bring up how yes women's
soccer is ahead of the curve by 20 years
but lost the U.S national uh to 15 year
old soccer team of boys from Dallas in
2017. Yeah well yeah but come on boys I
mean we all know that story by now yeah
I didn't bring it up because it's like
duh I also I think we're specific to
critiquing Rapinoe not all of women's
soccer I mean I'm not trying to dunk on
all of them unless they think that they
deserve equal pay in which case I want
them to be dunked on that's women's
basketball
which uh Megan rap no is married to sue
bird so oh
having these dinner table conversations
I guess great demoralize says Tim won't
read my anti-trump super chats anymore
likely because he knows that g no I'm
gonna stop right there I'm not gonna
finish reading your Super Chat because
you started it with Tim won't read my
anti-trump super chats which is bait and
so I will address it don't bait me bro
well congratulations I read half your
Super Chat
Joe Brown says there is a book called
psycho cybernetics by Maxwell maltz
self-improvement book he strongly
suggests therapy before plastic surgery
interesting trans people should have to
do the same look into it they do though
they're supposed to and then the issue
is we've had people
um like uh Helena kirschner she said
that she went to Planned Parenthood they
just gave her testosterone yeah they're
supposed to be therapy like they're
supposed to be you sit down you talk
they say hey we got to figure this out
and I think it's a question of how the
therapists are trained right so probably
if you're a modern you know you're
getting a degree in Psychology you're
going to be a psychiatrist you're not
gonna or you're a psychologist uh you're
going through universities that believe
a certain Narrative of what should
happen so there's no buy there's there's
only bias training yeah well that's the
problem is that like their duty to their
patient in terms of like doing no harm
they now have a skewed vision of what
harm is and so like how do you
how do you deal with these people moving
forward I just don't know
where are we at
let's grab another Super Chat a green
Clover is a second Super Chat tonight
problem with the draft is the p is the
people that the FED will need to fight
for the U.S are aware of the idea of a
false flag
yes but
the draft is for 18 year olds and while
it is true that 12th graders are skewing
towards uh conservative which means many
of these young guys are going to say no
way the good news is Harry Sisson has
done a great job of recruiting more
troops for Joe Biden's draft and when
the draft comes he's going to be right
there on the front line film and being
like come on everybody come on
that kid is something
it's something else
is so ridiculous the Xbox gamer says
Phil you crack me up because I have
always said that if I was six five I
would rule the world I'm only 6-1 the
short guy of the future
they were getting taller for a while so
one of the properties we have at
freedomastan is a barn a barn house
that's from the 1800s and the ceilings
are like seven feet right because people
were five foot two back in the day dude
I stayed in a hotel in San Francisco and
it was like a hundred plus year old
building and I couldn't even like my
shoulders were wider than the door frame
wow it was wild it was like little
people you still live there you know
crazy
Peggy says missing a penalty is easy
Messi does it all the time LOL aha but
like that right
yeah maybe I don't know
not in that moment Nathan B says I just
got back from Syria and we're giving
them Freedom or we might be guarding the
oil fields I'm not sure
even Trump said it was for the oil
that was that was pretty bold of him
it's like we're gonna keep troops in
there to guard the oil that's what we're
doing man Trump's gotta go on Joe Rogan
Joe's got to have him he'd be so much
fun
pbd was pushing it hard I know and I
think it's gonna happen I think it's
going to happen because Trump will do it
yeah well if he if he has any intention
of winning the presidency he has to say
yes to that can how long was the Trump
interviewed in Elk boys
I don't know because like can Trump
handle two or three hours of sitting
down in one hour no no it was like it
was like an hour I think dude he can he
can stand for that long and just riff
that's true I think it's similar to like
we have people who come who are supposed
to go out and they're like I maybe can
only do an hour and then they end up
staying the whole time because like you
get engaged in what you're doing it's
not like you're just answering hostile
questions for three hours
Brandon Smith says I just got out of the
Navy last week after 10 years out due to
Medical but I intended on getting out at
the end of my last contract and a large
reason was the Kinder gentler military
by the way heading back to West Virginia
and a farm here here
West Virginia is a good place there's a
lot of work we got to do but we're
working on it
the emperor's Champions is the only way
I'd accept being drafted is if the
Russians or Chinese land troops in
Alaska uh I don't even know if that
would work
if because Alaska is a far away land to
a lot of Americans
if it was U.S territory like California
or Florida or something then people
might be like oh holy smokes but the the
I stand by what I said even if troops
land in California as well especially if
it's California no no question you can
have it yup that's right it says the
native California yeah right half my
family's still Behind Enemy Lines I'm
like look you were already behind them
Enemy Lines with Newsom Mr bam says hey
Tim I've been watching this show since
2016 and this is the first time the live
show didn't show up uh on on my for you
page
this show has not existed since 2016.
this show was started in the beginning
of I believe 2020.
was it 2020 yeah I think so and it was
because of the lockdowns it was because
uh it wasn't so much because of the
lockdowns it was partly because of
lockdowns
yeah the lockdowns were a big component
of why we started doing a nightly show
so the point of that Super Chat is he's
saying that it's not coming up on its
homepage yeah yeah yeah
because YouTube plays dirty games but
that's why I always say at the start of
every show in the end share the show
with your friends and uh I genuinely
mean it if you if you take the URL of
the show and post it on Facebook ax
wherever they can't censor at all
they'll still try they'll still suppress
Facebook might try and hide it and stuff
and Google had us censored for a while
but uh it if you know look we've got you
know 30 some odd thousand people who
watch or watching right now if 30 000
people posted this online if they just
can't they can't do anything about that
that's what matters that's what matters
what do we have here
Aaron says the left is salivating at the
political right being anti-war they can
imprison and conscript their children
Middle America pays the worst price
during war
well life what is the impact of losing
men
yeah
Josh Berg says this was Megan rapino's
Super Saiyan moment she thought I can do
this to prove them I deserve it with all
her strength and Aura glows around her
her muscles grow with all that strength
screaming I deserve it she kick it clean
over
that's right maybe she's gonna retire
and become an uh NFL field goal cooker
like about the right range to me I'm not
very sports but there was mashups from
three year Letterman that were posted it
was her her lining up for the kick and
then it was like one of the kicks that
goes wide left against Alabama and they
just match the two together very funny
Callum dimmick says must be a good show
today I didn't get a notification and it
didn't appear on my homepage
dang
nowhere H says what do you think about
the major flood that's happening in
China it is on China observer's YouTube
channel really major flood
what's going on
um poor infrastructure choices over my
ears have ultimately led to a failure in
their levies and Etc et cetera you can
find more about a lot of people like
China Observer serpent Za uh like laoi
A6 people talk about it I don't know if
they've made any videos on I haven't
seen any if they've made any but it's
out there there's news so you're saying
that the US fired harp to
what's what's about the I don't know
maybe I could talk to you after the show
but the Kill The Boars uh oh yeah we
talked a little bit about it we talk
about again yeah there's more there's a
lot more news coming out because
apparently that dude doubled down
Millennium yeah and he started telling
people to actually go and take like just
crazy dude yeah yeah I wonder what the
sa uh Human Rights Commission is going
to say about that come on let's see what
they'll say about yeah New York Times is
going to be like oh calm down yeah so
they'll say and then it's like At first
the New York Times said it's basically
just a meme forget about it yeah and
then we're only like probably a few
months to a year away where they're like
oh calm down it's just white people
right yeah MSNBC the guy was interesting
like basically laughing about it and
then it's like okay well you know I
thought there's any any life is a big
deal for you guys right no apparently
not doesn't matter well it's just
bizarre because you have like RFK Jr
who's getting dragged for just using two
numbers that apparently we're no longer
allowed to use in a tweet and then
simultaneously you have people that are
overtly stating go kill a particular
group of people like and that's and
that's not to be concerned
blowing the people that are freaking out
about RFK saying that he was making a
Nazi reference I feel like that is kind
of like the jump the shark moment for
Nazi Stark where it's like where it's
like because some of the people it's
like yo look you can dislike RFK You can
disagree with him but nowadays like
there is no reason there's no history
that indicates an RFK is in any way a
white nationalist or anything and he's
been in the public eye forever for his
whole entire life this is the most
ridiculous thing that I've seen I can't
believe it and the people in the
libertarian party and you know who you
are that that actually got on that train
you are embarrassing and you should be
ashamed of yourselves
incredibly embarrassing all right Riley
Lewin says you should have Manju baturu
on he invented biteswa Pro China with
decent arguments would be an interesting
if heated conversation yeah that would
be interesting yeah culture War you want
to write it write it down yeah so right
now that'd be really cool to do America
V China culture War episode yeah that
would be cool but uh biteswa means uh
White left
in Chinese it basically means walk right
yeah what basically means Karen when do
we say wait what is that gonna trend on
Tick Tock that's what I want to know
this fights was trended periodically on
like Twitter and stuff
but it's not real until it reaches Tick
Tock with these youths very funny
oh okay we got a Super Chat Ryan Brown
says we are in a Resurgence of
conservative thought in the northern
hemisphere of the world followed by a
backlash against the establishment in
the northern hemisphere of the world the
Civil Wars in Europe before world war
three
than civil wars in Europe before World
War III very interesting
Guardsman norheim says as an Alaskan I
always get a chuckle how little the
lower 48 knows about us Russia owns Big
diomede Island we own little diamond
there you go
dude it'd be super cool to go to little
dimed
there's like a little little town there
or something that'd be crazy like what
do you do
we were I was looking at Onalaska and
there's like a house for sale there and
it looks really nice there was just like
one on Zillow and I'm like
how do you get there and what do you do
when you're there and do you just eat
crab all day it doesn't sound like a bad
Life by getting the crab out of the
water is probably rough and then what
happens when you know if like the
crabbing industry goes under it's like
the town just ceases to exist
well that's reality it's your it's your
bug out Frontier living man I don't know
I don't think Onalaska is a good place
to be in a bug out because there's
nowhere to go
well yeah but like there's also no one
to come take your stuff nah no that's
not true yeah yeah you're super close to
Russia relatively and there's a town
there and they want to set military
bases yeah so if you were on uh if
you're on the Asian landmass or the
North American
something happens like if if you know
the city got wiped out you can just
start driving somewhere else but if
you're on an island you ain't going
nowhere
do you have to hope no one no one pays
attention to you it's a cold Island you
know well and you can you I mean you you
could set up a perimeter I don't know I
think you're in trouble if you're on
that island it's like what are you
eating you have to farm fish I guess you
just fish all day you need vegetables
man
there's like probably probably a very
low growing season that far north
I don't know man just go to svalbard and
go live in the uh seed seed uh what is
it the seed vault
all right Sergeant Buck says microwave
plus human brain equal equals microwave
CJ gibsy says Black Mirror had an
episode where a copy of someone's
Consciousness is enslaved to run the
person's smart home has the copy
tortured to comply that was a crate I
saw that that was crazy like basically
if the AI refused to comply they would
have to experience like a year of of
solitary confinement because the person
who owned the device could be like one
year and then the AI experience total
isolation for one year in the span of 10
seconds and then comes back being like
stop please I'll do whatever you say wow
yeah so crazy all right everybody if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the share with your
friends if you like it and head over to
timcast.com click join us become a
member to watch the members on the
uncensored show coming up in just a few
minutes we're going to talk about
naughty things you can follow the show
at timcast IRL you can follow me
personally at timcast Clint do you want
to shout anything out yeah I have uh
speaking of RFK Junior the guy who he he
agreed to debate him on uh the Russia
Ukraine crisis was Max Blumenthal I will
be having him on later in this week on
liberty lockdown I will also have the Q
Anon Shaman and Dave Smith over the next
week so a stacked lineup go to YouTube
subscriber liberty lockdown or just
search on your favorite audio podcaster
and this week also go check out Tower
gang and if you are sick of the duopolis
go check out Town don't go check out
Target it's gonna be it's we have Elijah
Schaefer on tomorrow it's gonna be fun
uh but uh yeah if you are the dilopoly
and you want to uh you know actually
have people that care about Liberty
check out the libertarian party
I am uh Phil that remains on X I am Phil
that remains official on Instagram the
band is All That Remains are available
on Spotify Apple music uh Pandora and
the YouTubes I'm here brimwell I'm a
writer for this super cool news site the
best timcast.com uh you can go to
website click on the read tab see all of
our work and follow at timcast news on
Twitter and Instagram I specifically
want to shout out uh Adrian Norman who's
got something up with about uh maj3 and
everything he's working on so check that
out and Shane Cashman has been covering
the Long Island serial killer trial and
I forgot to shout it out last week you
should definitely check it out if you
want to follow me you can follow me on
Instagram at hannahclear.b and on
Twitter at HC brimlow thank you guys so
much
uh I'm serge.com on Twitter it's not X
on my phone yet so I'm not going to
start calling you X anytime soon and I'm
on Instagram and YouTube and all that
stuff surge.com will spell it out see
you guys we'll see you all over at
timcast.com thanks for hanging out